nos piden aproximar la raíz principal o
la raíz positiva de 45 al centésimo más
cercano y supongo que no están pidiendo
que lo hagamos con calculadora eso sería
demasiado fácil veamos si podemos
aproximar esto simplemente con pluma y
papel así es que la raíz cuadrada de 45
o la raíz principal de 45 45 no es un
cuadrado perfecto definitivamente no es
un cuadrado perfecto pero cuáles son las
raíces cuadradas perfectas alrededor de
raíz de 45 veamos a raíz de 49 es mayor
que raíz de 45 raíz de 49 que es 7 al
cuadrado así es que es menor que la raíz
cuadrada de 49 y mayor que la raíz
cuadrada de 36 así es que la raíz
cuadrada de 36 o la raíz principal de 36
debería decir es 6 mientras que la raíz
principal de 49 es 7 tenemos entonces
que este valor de aquí
este valor de aquí va a estar entre 6 y
7 y si nos fijamos bien está a sólo 4
unidades de 49 mientras que está a 9
unidades de 36 así es que el espacio que
hay entre 6 al cuadrado y 7 al cuadrado
es 13 y 45 se ubica a 9 unidades en ese
espacio así es que a manera de
aproximación aunque no va a funcionar
perfectamente porque esta no es una
relación lineal
estamos sacando la raíz cuadrada el
valor va a estar más cercano a 7 de lo
que está a 6 por lo menos el cuadrado 45
está a 93 ya vos entre ellos
así es que podríamos probar podríamos
probar este número es muy cercano a dos
tercios así es que vamos a probar 6.7
probemos entonces 6.7 basados en que 93
ya vos es casi dos tercios de hecho
hagamos el cálculo simplemente para
entretenernos entonces cuántas veces
cabe
veamos cuántas veces cabe 13 en 9
agregamos el punto decimal y 3 ceros y
entonces hacemos la división 90 entre 13
13 cabe seis veces 90 si ok esto es 90
entre 13 es igual a 6 6 por 3 18
llevamos 16 por 16 y una que llevamos 7
restando 90 menos 78 nos da 12 vemos
entonces que esta división es casi 7 por
lo cual este valor es muy cercano a
punto 7 ahora dividimos 120 entre 13 y
esto nos da que 9 si 120 entre 13 es 99
por 327 déjame deshacerme de este 19 por
327 llevamos 29 por 19 y 211 hacemos la
redesta y nos quedan 3 de residuos así
es que 9 13 a voces punto 69 por lo que
6.7 es una buena aproximación 93 y hago
6.69 la distancia entre 36 y 49 por lo
que pongamos de manera muy aproximada
que es punto 69
ya que hay entre 36 y 49 se insiste que
este valor es una aproximación no tiene
que ser exacta usamos este valor como
una aproximación y vemos qué tan preciso
es entonces probemos probemos con 6.7 y
la manera de probar esto es elevando al
cuadrado multiplicando el número por sí
mismo entonces 6.7 x 6.7 sticks es un
signo de multiplicación por 6.7 tenemos
entonces que 7 por 7 49 llevamos 4 7 por
6 42 y 4 46 ponemos el 0 porque nos
hemos movido un lugar hacia la izquierda
ahora tenemos 6 por 7 6 por 7 es 42
llevamos 4 6 por 6 36 y 4 40 hagamos la
suma 9 096 y 28 4 y 0 4 y el 4 que
bajamos aquí tenemos un número a la
derecha del punto decimal aquí tenemos
otro número a la derecha el punto
decimal así es que el resultado de esto
es 44.89 así es que 6.7 nos acerca
bastante
aunque no estamos en realidad no estamos
aún al nivel de centésimos aquí sólo
tenemos una aproximación a nivel de
decimos
así es que 6.7 o más bien el cuadrado de
6.7 es aún menor de 45 o 6.7 es aún
menor que la raíz cuadrada de 45
probemos entonces 6.71 probemos entonces
6.71 déjame hacerlo con otro color
voy a poner 6.71 con rosa incrementamos
un poquito para ver si podemos ir de
44.89 45 porque este es un valor que
está realmente cercano a 45 probemos
entonces 6.71 de nueva cuenta tenemos
que hacer algo de aritmética a mano
suponemos que no quieren que usemos una
calculadora para esto uno por uno es 1 1
por 7 7 1 por 6 6 ponemos el 0 7 por 1 7
7 por 7 49 llevamos 4 7 por 6 42 y 4 46
agregamos dos ceros ahora 6 por 16 6 por
7 42
llevamos 4 otro nuevo 46 por 636 y 4 que
tenemos aquí es 40 es interesante ver
que tanto hemos avanzado con este
centésimo que hemos agregado bueno
hagamos la suma y vamos a poder valorar
esto entonces haciendo la suma que
tenemos
empezamos con 17 714 llevamos 17 y 9 16
y 6 son 22 llevamos 22 y 6 8 y 2 son 10
llevamos 14 y 15 y finalmente el 4 que
bajamos aquí tenemos uno dos tres cuatro
números después del punto decimal así es
que es uno dos tres cuatro pero tenemos
entonces que seis puntos 71 elevado al
cuadrado es igual a 45.02 41 entonces
hemos obtenido un número que es
ligeramente mayor que la raíz de 45
pongamos esto claramente obtuvimos que
6.7 es menor que la raíz de 45
a raíz de 45 es menor que 6.71 pues
cuando elevamos al cuadrado este número
obtuvimos un número ligeramente mayor
que 45 el punto clave aquí es que cuando
elevamos esto cuando elevamos 6.7
obtuvimos 44.89 que se ubica a 11
centésimos a 11 centésimas de 45 y si
ahora si ahora consideramos 6.71 al
cuadrado notamos que se ubica a 2.41
centésimos de 45 por lo cual este valor
es más cercano a la raíz de 45 si
estamos aproximando al centésimo más
cercano
definitivamente elegimos 6.71